-As President Biden touted
his infrastructure plan
to create jobs
and stimulate the economy,
one of the signature scams
of the Trump era,
a deal that was also supposed to
create jobs
and stimulate the economy,
fell apart, revealing yet again
that the GOP's new brand of
supposed pro-worker populism
is a giant fraud.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Let me just say
right off the bat
that we are aware that
federal investigators
executed search warrants
of Rudy Giuliani's office
and apartment this morning,
and I promise we will have a lot
more to say about it tomorrow
because there is no subject
nearer and dearer to our hearts
than Rudy Giuliani
being a giant [bleep]
I'm guessing, when they arrived,
Rudy tried to flush his phone
down the toilet
as the feds were carrying away
the toilet.
"Sir, it's a floor model.
It's not attached to anything."
"Oh, no, Rudy, ya dope!
You're supposed to have pipes."
Also, President Biden
delivered his first address
to a joint session of Congress
tonight.
And we're taping this
beforehand,
so we don't know what he said,
but something tells me he had
a slightly different energy
than the speeches he attended
as President Obama's VP,
where he was always doing stuff
like grabbing John Boehner's arm
or giving finger guns
to people in the crowd
like he was walking around
a villa in Miami Beach
making sure everyone at
the pool party was having fun.
"Cam, that glass looks empty.
You need a refill?
Stacy, I better see you
in the pool later.
I got the jets turned on.
Brad, throw another dog
on the grill for me.
I worked up an appetite kicking
Steve's ass in volleyball.
You got to work on your dig,
Steve."
One thing we do know
about Biden's speech
is that he has very likely
spent some time
touting his infrastructure plan,
and as he pitches that plan,
he's also dealing with
an intransigent GOP
that has its own idea
for infrastructure,
a GOP that's also trying to
rebrand itself
after decades of subservience
to corporate interests
as a populist,
pro-workers party.
They've gone from defending
so-called job creators
and decrying class warfare
to calling corporations
that don't side with them
on cultural issues woke.
-This past month,
we have seen the rise
of the woke corporation.
We have seen the rise
of big business
enforcing a woke standard.
-I think corporate America,
by trying to genuflect
to this wokeness,
I think they have gone down
a really bad road.
They're going to tie themselves
in knots
trying to please
the extreme left.
-Senator McConnell
says corporations
are, quote, behaving like
woke parallel governments
and becoming like a vehicle
for far-left mobs
to hijack our country.
-Let's just cut to the chase.
The big tech platforms
are owned and operated
by woke capitalists.
They're leftists.
They're liberals.
-There's no way Mark Zuckerberg
is woke.
At most, he's switched on.
And none of those Plutocrats
are leftists.
I'm pretty sure Jeff Bezos
and Bernie Sanders
aren't on the same page when it
comes to most political issues.
I doubt Bernie even uses Amazon.
"I get everything I need
from the co-op,
and when I run out of batteries,
I just connect some copper wire
to a potato.
Hey, turn down the A/C.
Potatoes don't grow on trees."
And just because
they pulled some Dr. Seuss books
with racist language
and put out statements
against voter suppression laws
doesn't mean companies
like Amazon and Delta
are suddenly woke.
For one thing, they both
tried to bust unions.
Amazon put up anti-union posters
in employee bathrooms,
and Delta handed out flyers
that said,
"Union dues cost
around $700 a year.
A new video game system with
the latest hits sounds like fun.
Put your money towards that
instead of paying dues
to the union."
Yeah, exactly. And if you
get sick in real life,
all you have to do is
hit a brick with your head
until a mushroom pops out.
The point is, these
giant corporations
aren't suddenly woke
just because they've done
the bare minimum of, say,
coming out against
racist voter suppression laws.
But Republicans are still
infuriated by that,
so they've tried to co-opt
the anti-corporate language
of actual left-wing populists
like Bernie, Elizabeth Warren,
and AOC.
For example,
Florida Senator Marco Rubio
wrote an absolutely ludicrous
screed
against supposedly
woke corporations
in the "New York Post"
this week,
where he said, "No policymaker
would allow a company
to dump toxic waste into a river
upstream of a thriving town
he is charged with governing.
Yet corporate America eagerly
dumps woke, toxic nonsense
into our culture,
and it's only gotten
more destructive with time.
These campaigns will be met
with the same strength
that any other polluter
should expect."
What any other polluter
should expect?
So, basically, total and
complete loyalty from the GOP?
Republicans cut so many
environmental regulations,
I'm pretty sure
they made it legal
to sell toxic sludge
as an energy drink.
And do I drink a sludge
every now and then?
Yeah.
That's only because
I'm up all night
writing this week's corrections.
These guys are, in many way,
just following
in Donald Trump's footsteps.
He was not in any serious way
a populist,
except that he co-opted
some of the language of populism
while doling out trillions
in giveaways
to corporations that mostly just
gave the money
to their wealthy investors.
Trump, for example,
said the 2017 tax cuts
would be rocket fuel
for the economy,
and earlier this month, Senate
Minority Leader Mitch McConnell
said rolling them back
would destroy jobs.
-This tax bill of 2017, undone,
would create an extensive loss
of jobs in our country,
do exactly the wrong thing,
and move us
in the wrong direction.
-You hear that,
woke corporations?
The Republican party
is on to you.
If you don't stop dumping
woke toxic waste
into our cultural river,
then we are going to punish you
by allowing you to...
continue paying zero dollars
in federal income taxes.
That can't be right. Wally,
I think the card is wrong.
-That's what it said
in the script.
-But does it seem right to you?
-Hey, Seth, I just write
the cards, baby.
-Wally, the only way
you could be cooler
is if you wore sunglasses
under your face shield.
Anyway, the point is,
this is the scam.
Republicans call themselves
pro-worker populists
while doling out cash
to giant companies
who mostly use it to decrease
their tax liabilities
and enrich
their wealthy investors,
even though the whole point
was supposed to be
to use that money to invest
in the economy and create jobs.
And there was a perfect test
case of this scam in Wisconsin
at the start
of Trump's presidency.
-After months of speculation,
Foxconn promises
to build its first American
factory here in Wisconsin.
-It's the largest
economic development project
in state history
and will initially require more
than 16,000 construction jobs
sourced from
Wisconsin businesses.
The LCD manufacturing campus
expected to be operational
in 2020
and the project
expected to have
at least a $7 billion annual
economic impact on the state.
-And with this project
moving forward,
Governor Walker coined
a new term today,
the Wisconn Valley,
describing our area as a new hub
for technology and innovation.
-They wouldn't have done it here
except that I became president,
so that's good.
Congratulations on truly
one of the eighth wonders.
I think we can say this is --
We can say the eighth wonder
of the world.
This is the eighth wonder
-Yeah, it goes great pyramids,
the Colossus of Rhodes,
and then a factory in Wisconsin.
You get the sense Trump has used
"eighth wonder of the world"
to describe a lot of his
projects over the years.
"Trump Taj Mahal --
It's going to be
the eighth wonder of the world.
Blackjack tables,
cocktail waitresses,
and we're going to
pump in oxygen
to keep people gambling longer,
just like the guy
who built the real Taj Mahal,
the Emperor Shah Jahan.
Great guy. Great guy.
Met him at Studio 54
back in '86.
He was there
with Christie Brinkley.
She went on to marry Billy Joel,
Mr. Piano Guy himself.
You know, I love the song
'We Didn't Start the Fire,'
but I always thought
'Trump' should be in that song.
A lot of famous people
in there, but no Trump.
What do we think, folks?
Should Trump be --
Should 'Trump' be in
'We Didn't Start the Fire'?
Space monkey, Mafia,
Donald Trump --
Has a nice ring to it.
You don't want to mess with
the space monkey Mafia.
Almost impossible to do
construction on other planets."
"Got to kick back
a lot of space bananas.
You know, they'll say...
they'll say Trump
tried to start the fire,
but we know that's not true.
We know that's not true."
The Foxconn deal was supposed to
be the shining example
of Trump's claim that he was
bringing manufacturing jobs
back to the United States,
and it was proof of concept for
the Republican way of doing it,
not by investing directly
in infrastructure
but by doling out subsidies
to big companies.
Trump was even there for
the ground-breaking ceremony
with then Wisconsin Governor
Scott Walker,
where he picked up some dirt
with a gold shovel
and then gently tossed it back
on the ground
near the spot where
he dug it up from.
"There you go.
I loosened it up for you."
For a guy who was supposedly
in construction,
he doesn't even know
how to fake it.
If you handed him a hammer, he
would talk it into like a phone.
"Send me your best nail guy."
Under the deal,
Foxconn was promised
a stunning $4 billion
in taxpayer subsidies,
and, in return, they were
supposed to spend $10 billion
employing 13,000 people
at a 20-million-square-foot
manufacturing campus
in Wisconsin
and instantly
establish Wisconsin
as a destination
for tech firms.
Again, this was supposed to be
proof positive
of Trump's ability to magically
bring back manufacturing jobs
without actually making
any of the real direct
investments in the economy
that, say, Joe Biden and the
Democrats are now proposing.
It was also a distillation
of the core GOP philosophy,
which is that if you
give massive handouts
to giant businesses that are
already flush with cash
instead of giving the money
directly to workers,
those handouts will eventually
trickle down and create jobs.
And credit, where it's due,
the plan worked.
The project has been
a huge success.
What's that? It wasn't.
Shoemaker, you got to tell me
this stuff before the show.
This is not cool.
Wally, are you cool with this?
-I'm cool with everything,
baby.
-Rock and roll, Wally.
How can I stay mad?
The point is, the Foxconn deal
was a giant scam.
It was obvious it was a scam
from the very beginning.
For one thing,
they kept missing key goals
and failing to deliver
on their promises,
cycling from one idea
to the next.
This is a real summary
of all the different projects
Foxconn considered for the site.
The company spent years pivoting
wildly from idea to idea.
The enormous
Gen 10.5 LCD factory
specified in the contract
became a far smaller Gen 6,
then was canceled,
then came back.
The company announced
it was building something
called the AI+8K+5G ecosystem
to be developed in a network
of innovation centers,
buildings that the company
purchased only to leave empty.
It looked into building
fish farms,
exporting ice cream,
storing boats.
It announced plans to build
coffee kiosks and ventilators
that never moved forward.
Most recently, it said it would
build electric cars,
though maybe,
the company acknowledged,
that will happen in Mexico.
Man, that sounds like how I plan
a Mother's Day gift for my wife.
I'm going to commission
a painting of our family.
Nope,
I don't have time for that.
I'm going to take a picture
of our family.
Nope, ran out of time.
I'm going to find an existing
picture of our family
and have it framed.
Nope, I don't have time.
I'm going find an existing
picture of our family
and text it her with
"Happy Mother's Day."
Nope, I'm going to forget
entirely,
and then I'm gonna wake up
two Sundays from now
in an empty bed
while it slowly dawns on me
that I am [bleep]
"Honey, I built you a place
to store boats."
And yet, as this scam
was unfolding,
the village where the campus
was supposed to be located
was in the process
of buying up properties
and building new roads
to make way
for this fancy new factory
they were promised.
Wisconsin has already spent
at least $400 million
on land and infrastructure,
and as of 2019, the village
where the plant is located
had paid just over $152 million
for 132 properties
to make way for Foxconn,
plus $7.9 million
in relocation costs.
Meanwhile, Foxconn
owns a lot of real estate
in southern Wisconsin now,
and it has built
an odd collection of buildings,
including the
million-square-foot structure
it called the LCD Fab
and a glass orb.
Cool, so now
instead of 13,000 jobs
building high-tech
LCD displays,
taxpayers ended up spending
hundreds of millions of dollars
on a useless glass orb.
Although, shout-out
to Donald Trump
on being our first
two-orb President.
What do you even do with a glass
orb you don't need anymore?
Turn it into a community center?
"All right, kids,
it's time for recess.
Everyone line up
outside the glass orb,
and remember,
do not touch the orb.
We still don't know what it does
or what its powers are."
Or maybe they'll use it as
a Packers training facility.
"All right, go long,
but remember,
don't run into the glass wall
again."
But it gets even crazier
than that
because the state
actually demolished homes
and built new roads that,
in a metaphor
that's almost "two" on the nose,
actually lead to nowhere.
Former President Trump announced
Foxconn was coming
July 26, 2017.
The following June, Trump,
former Congressman Paul Ryan,
and former Governor Scott Walker
were among those
who broke ground on the plant
in Mount Pleasant.
And since then,
roads have been widened,
land flattened,
homes demolished,
and the plant has not built
anything yet.
-I was there. It's the
weirdest thing, Bertha.
There's basically
a giant clear dome
that I think is some kind
of data center/museum,
a couple of big warehouses,
and then farms
and some homes down the street.
It is --
There's a bunch of new roads
that kind of lead to nowhere.
-What did they use
for the blueprints,
an M.C. Escher dorm room poster?
A giant orb and a bunch of roads
that lead to nowhere.
This whole thing is starting to
sound like a David Lynch
project.
Did they also give them
$4 billion
to build
a state-of-the-art red room
where a little man in a red suit
teaches you how to dance
and talk in reverse?
And even now that Foxconn has
mostly abandoned the project,
they're still scooping up
taxpayer handouts
even as they leave behind
a trail of debt,
broken promises, and chaos.
Foxconn is still eligible for
$80 million in tax subsidies,
and under the revised deal,
the state is still paying
a per-job subsidy
of about $55,000.
$55,000 for each job.
Instead of giving that
to a massive foreign company,
how about you give that
directly to workers
to build useful stuff here,
like bridges
and broadband infrastructure,
instead of roads to nowhere
and a giant glass orb that's
just going to sit there empty
and inevitably cause
traffic delays?
"Honey, I'm going to go to
Kroger to pick up some milk.
I'll be back in about two hou--
The road leads to nowhere.
I got to go around
the giant orb.
What do you mean,
which giant orb?
The Foxconn orb.
Turn off the hairdryer if you
want to have this conversation."
So as Biden talks up
his infrastructure plan
which would raise
corporate taxes
in order to make
direct investments in workers
to build things
we actually need,
the Foxconn scam
is a cautionary tale about
what Republicans would have us
do with that money instead.
They want to shovel handouts
to giant corporations
already flush with cash,
and all the while,
they're ludicrously trying
to rebrand themselves as a party
of pro-worker populists.
Say what you will
about a scam like this,
but one thing's for sure.
-They wouldn't have done it here
except that I became president.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wear a mask.
Get vaccinated. We love you.